a Florida police officers being praised
for a unique act of kindness he helped a
homeless man land a job cell phone video
captured officer Tony Carlson as his
name
assisting a man named Phil with a shave
in Tallahassee why did he do that
vladimir duthiers our streaming network
cbsn shows us why the officer stepped
right in Blatt good morning good morning
officer Carlson was in a gas station
parking lot last Sunday after finishing
a call and that is when he encountered
Phil who would end up having a positive
run-in with the law
serving the community isn't just a job
for Tony Carlson it's a way of life you
know you get on the scene you try to
resolve it in a way that there's going
to be a positive outcome that'll last so
when the Tallahassee police officer
arrived at a gas station and came across
a homeless man named Phil who was
struggling to fix an electric razor
he lent him a hand I went over there and
took a look at it it was missing a screw
so I was able to tighten up the other
screw tight enough where it would work
and while I was doing that he was
telling me the story that and he seemed
really excited that excitement was an
opportunity to work at the McDonald's
next door with one exception Monday he
was trying to shave he obviously outside
didn't have a mirror anything and he was
just getting patch after patch and
wasn't going too well so I said hey Phil
if you want me to do that here I could
probably get it done a lot quicker what
happened next was unexpectedly caught on
camera by a stranger the video quickly
spread online and my wife had called me
and she said hey did you shave some guy
today so she had already seen it on
Facebook
officer Carlson says he hopes the moment
serves as a lesson for others if
somebody seeing this that gets in the
situation where they can help somebody
out they'll remember this and maybe take
a chance and do something good for
somebody else
officer Carlson told us he's planning to
help Phil get some paperwork in order so
he can get an ID a social security
number which he of course needs to be
hired he said Phil told him he's hoping
this job will get him off the street and
into an apartment we like officer
Carlson will you love I saw this officer
car right I think he's I think he's an
awesome guy
last night I saw it on evening news I
love the story bar to protect and shave
right officer first yeah officer second
certainly do that as many do thanks so
much flat